now to a and 6a are each in their own
way slightly more difficult than what we
had a look at at the start what's great
about them is we could think through the
same kinds of strategies and see how
they're useful now right out the gate
here's to a right we know at least we
have these two potential strategies and
we can choose either one both of them
should work but it's a matter of which
one might be more efficient which might
be quicker Merrick what do you reckon I
agree with Merrick that division makes
sense how do we know that divisions the
most helpful one what did we use here
let me put that question back to what it
was what facts could we take advantage
of Merrick you I know you know cuz you
suggested it could someone else tell me
what we were looking at we recognition
yeah - what about it fantastic - that's
exactly right
two is a factor six so I can divide both
sides evenly and I'll still be in a
whole number land which is come to us
right so let's go ahead and do it I
divide this side by two in fact I'm
gonna go ahead and write it if you stop
doing this I encourage you to go back to
it because so helpful what do you get on
the left-hand side yeah I don't have
that two anymore I got rid of it by
division on the right hand side three
fantastic now at this point remember
what I try to get is the Pro numeral by
itself on the left hand side so the
thing that's in the way of that is
currently a six what should I do to get
rid of it I'll subtract 6 from both
sides okay so that leaves me with the
takeaway X on that side the negative and
then 3 take away 6 is negative 3 so I've
got two negatives flying around here and
so I want to get rid of both of them
what should I do to both sides I should
multiply or divide they both do the same
thing I'm gonna multiply both sides by
negative 1 ok that turns the negative X
into just X and it turns the negative 3
into 3 now just a quick side note some
of you may have solved the problem
exactly like this but there is another
way if you wanted to you like gross all
these negatives flying around I can go
from this
here and get rid of the negatives right
away right instead of getting rid of six
I'm gonna try and get rid this negative
X what should I do to both sides to get
rid of negative X now I could I could do
this like I did before but I want to try
and see if there's another way I can do
this
I think I heard Louise could you repeat
it again all right if I add X to both
sides right adding X to this what
happens to it the minus X and the plus X
when you put in together zero so you
just end up with the six but then I add
an X to the left-hand side so I should
probably add it to the right-hand side
that gives me ah now I had three X that
was what I heard but that's not adding X
to the right-hand side is it yeah this
is multiplication isn't it very good so
I should do something else I should be
writing plus that's what I'm doing both
sides plus X and now to get to the
answer which I know is true I should
subtract three from both sides and this
is the same as this I just would
normally write the XML left-hand side
any questions on that that make sense ma
did you have a thought or a question yes
you absolutely could so if you wanted I
could turn this top line into twelve
take away two X and then off you go one
of the reasons why expanding brackets is
sometimes I try to avoid it because it
always sorry take that back it almost
always makes your numbers bigger doesn't
it right so your numbers get larger and
there's more ways for errors to turn up
I like small numbers they're good for my
brain because my brain small okay last
one quickly this is 6a and then the rest
of the exercise I'm gonna let you guys
have it go out okay so could you drop
down this question with me I know you're
most of your not art which is fine but
jot it down now in this case here this
is a perfect example of where searching
for a factor and dividing not a good way
to go is it because you've got this five
at the front here you had this four
they're not gonna play ball together are
they so what would our other strategy
it's on the board in orange I'm going to
starts with an e I'm gonna expand I'll
get rid of all the brackets and then
I'll be good to go from this so
can you please help me expand the left
hand side what should I write down five
X minus five fantastic make sure you do
both of those terms and then on the
right hand side let's expand that four X
plus eight fantastic okay from here it's
the same kind of problem we had before
Marik do you have a thought or a
question okay we're not ready for the
answer I want the answer but I want it
off to I know how I got there
okay let's have a look someone want to
suggest what I could do here okay Carol
you reckon plus five so that'll get rid
of this number over here so I'll write
that is five x equals 4x that hasn't
changed
plus 13 so you can see the extra five
where it's a pube next step subtract 4x
I want all the perennials over here
right so I will subtract 4x from here
leaving me of how many X's just one of
them equals 13 I'm done okay how you
feeling how's your brain going sad all
right which part you confused by Mary
can't let's just pause and make sure we
know what Marik's done right
Krishan suggestion I think it was was to
add five at this point which landed us
here okay
marek suggestion was to not add five but
to subtract 4x now I'm just gonna point
out and it was my fault I didn't write
it when you have a look at what we were
doing on each step we expanded Kashan
said this had five ah who said take away
4x a lot of you said take away 4 exactly
right that's what we did do you notice
Marik has done this he's just done it
one step earlier see that he's done one
step earlier but then at this point what
did he have to do he had two plus five
having to do the same things we did but
he just reversed the order now not all
things can be like this you can't always
change the order of things just because
you want to write like 7 take away 5 you
can't just change the order of that and
say 5 take away 7 and not the same thing
but in many cases and you've just
stumbled on one of them
in many cases it doesn't matter which
way you go about it we all ended up on
an x equals 13